und wir berichten heute den ganzen tag
darüber wie deutschland langsam wieder
hochfährt
deutschland macht wieder auf geschäfte
mit weniger als 800 quadratmetern
verkaufsfläche wieder öffnen
für die händler ist das seit langem
endlich wieder eine gute nachricht so zu
wirtschaften dass ich das alles endlich
angefangen hat zu lohnen
ja und dann kam die korona pandemie je
nach bundesland und stadt müssen
besondere vorsichtsmaßnahmen eingehalten
werden ohne sicherheitsabstand
desinfektionsmittel und teilweise auch
mundschutz geht daher nichts
die gesetzlichen beschränkungen setzen
mit dem unsere eigenen mitarbeiter diese
masken tragen und wir ein hinweisschild
draußen vorm laden positionieren die
sekunde daraufhin gewesen sein dass sich
daran zu halten haben und wir versuchen
sicherzustellen dass eben pro verkäufer
wir sind zu zweit im verkauf immer nur
ein kunde mit dem programmnamen ist wir
lassen nur bis zu fünf kunden rein in
den laden wir sind 100 quadratmeter
laden und dann werde das so geregelt
dass wir einkaufs körbchen vor die tür
stellen stimmt und wenn sie aufgebraucht
werden da kommt keiner mehr rein
natürlich maske natürlich abstand für
restaurants gelten die lockerungen
bisher nicht sie müssen nach wie vor
geschlossen bleiben
der einzelhandel also besonders stark
getroffen und wie gesagt die regelungen
sind sehr stark unterschiedlich von
bundesland zu bundesland und wir wollen
jetzt sprechen mit den kollegen terminus
baum der in leipzig ist guten morgen
naja wir melden uns aus leipzig aus dem
laden von männern i look steht die steht
jetzt in meiner seite hat man auch
gerade im einspieler gesehen wie sie
gestern ihr geschäft schon vorbereitet
hat auf die neueröffnung heute nach vier
wochen männer nie wie hast du das
geschafft in dieser zeit zu überlegen
was hast du getan möglich mitzunehmen
und die sind mitgegangen ist eigentlich
gelungen eins zu eins weil ich meine die
umsätze vorzuführen und für unsere
kunden sein zu können
er verkauft viele kleider- und bzw auch
stoffe und in diesem zusammenhang hast
du dann einen neuen geschäftszweig quasi
entdeckt werde ich über wasser gehalten
werden
ein zweiter laden ist und einfach
personal überhaupt nicht möglich war
habe jetzt einfach die chance gesetz das
zu machen und man schauen wie das jetzt
parallel läuft beziehungsweise dann im
nachgang weiterlaufen kann genau nicht
nur der online shop ich meine auch die
gesichtsmasken die du nicht sortiment
genommen hast eine kostet 16 euro 90 da
denkt man ja ganz schön viel aber er
machte auch selbst wie setzt sich dieser
preis genau zu sehen
genau da setzt sich natürlich für die
durch die lohnkosten zusammen
für die ganze zeit er wird dafür nutzen
um das aufzubauen wir haben den letzten
drei wochen quasi in die
produktentwicklung gehabt also wir sind
ja worte label in erster linie und haben
dann wohnt anspruch an tieren das
ästhetische design und deswegen haben
wir das in drei wochen und mein team und
ich weil weiterentwickelt und der steckt
viel arbeit drin und jetzt mal so
optimiert ist von der große schlag zahl
erreichen können und jeden tag
würgespiele masten produzieren können
und es ist pflicht das heute in sachsen
ab heute in bus und bahn und in
geschäften masken getragen werden
mussten
wie meinst du da kaufte sich das in den
nächsten wochen das lässt sich das haben
wir auch gemerkt ich denke das wird
jetzt den ein oder anderen der es noch
nicht geglaubt hat auch erreichen dass
das jetzt so pflicht sein werden
und damit zurück nach berlin ganz
herzlichen dank euch beiden alles gute
für die eröffnung herzlichen dank für
die zuschaltung aus leipzig und jetzt
wollen wir nach münchen schalten nämlich
zum kollegen jacob mail der mit nicole
mohrmann im laden ist ja drei leben in
münchen und darf nicht öffnen guten
morgen guten morgen und servus nach
berlin
ja ich stehe hier bei nicole mohrmann im
geschäft sie da heute noch nicht öffnen
erst in einer woche in münchen darf
heute dürfen heute baumärkte und
gartencenter erst geöffnet werden
frau moormann was wie haben sie die
letzten vier wochen erlebt ist natürlich
wahnsinnig schwierig werden davon einmal
von anderen tag die lebensgrundlage
quasi genommen wird weil wir machen
stationären einzelhandel und wir müssen
verkaufen in unserer lokalen geschäften
ich habe drei geschäfte
dieser umsatz ist jetzt ausgefallen wir
haben versucht irgendwie anders mit dem
kunden kontakt zu bleiben über social
media und instagram ein bisschen verkauf
zu generieren es ist uns gelungen
vermindert aber ich hab' september
erlebt 2001 und ich habe die finanzkrise
28 erlebt aber das jetzt ist natürlich
noch mal was ganz anderes
und sie haben wir auch noch eine
forderung an die nicht an die politik
sondern auch an
andere gesellschaftliche kräfte wie sie
mir gesagt ja also ich finde dass unsere
regierung das eigentlich ganz großartig
macht weil das ist eine neue situation
für alle und keiner weiß wie so richtig
weiter geht und ich bin auch mit bayern
total happy und zufrieden aber alle
einzelhändler alle gastronomen sitzen in
einem boot
es ist nicht von uns gemacht sondern wir
können nicht in unserer lokalität
verkaufen und unser geld verdienen und
der vermieter sitzt am längeren hebel
und es ist einfach schwierig wenn das
nur aufgeschoben wird wenn es nur
gestundet wird eigentlich müssen die
vermieter auch ein schritt jetzt auf den
einzelhandel und auf die gastronomie
zugehen und eine lösung finden die für
beide akzeptabel ist das ist ganz ganz
wichtig in der zeit weil sonst werden
wir in einem halben jahr eine
pleitewelle in deutschland erleben die
ohne worte sein wird und mit dieser
einschätzung zurück nach berlin
ganz herzlichen danke danke auch an
nicole mohrmann für diese einschätzung
und einen dringenden appell auch an die
vermieter weil der einzelhandel eben
besonders schwer getroffen ist und wie
wir gesehen haben in münchen noch nicht
aufmachen darf in leipzig schon in
hannover dürfen die möbelhäuser wieder
aufmachen und zugeschaltet ist jetzt der
möbelhaus chef robert hesse der wieder
aufmachen darf guten morgen hessen aus
garten ist wie funktioniert das in
hannover was darf jetzt aufmachen und
was nicht ja das ist so ganz ist so
einfach also die eine größe aus will
muss nicht wie zum beispiel
wir sind allerdings ihre postweg 100
grad meter
denn schwer es ist wir brauchen zum
beispiel beim gewerbegebiet es eben an
ein auge mit einigen geschlossen aber er
ist wie machen sie das denn sie haben ja
auch deutlich größere verkaufsfläche als
diese 800 quadratmeter wir haben sich
dann trat meter ende unsere gartenbild
unsere küchen welt
normal sind genommen haben den
eingangsbereich einander getrennt und
herzlichen danke hesse wir haben leider
schlechten ton ich mich trotzdem
abschließend fragen wie sie ihre
mitarbeiter und die besucher jetzt
schützen sie haben gerade kurz erklärt
wie sie die fläche vermindern auch von
50.000 eben runter auf die 800 dass sie
teile abgesperrt haben trotzdem noch mal
ganz kurz die frage wie sie die
mitarbeiter schützen und weiter abstand
bz wie einkaufswagen
nach dem herzlichen dank hesse aus
hannover danke dass sie sich
zugeschaltet haben und alles gute für
den neustart heute und wir wollen auch
staaten in den landkreis heinsberg
diesem kreis in nrw der schwer getroffen
ist von dem ausbruch der korona pandemie
und auch dort zu unserer reporterin lisa
unfair
guten morgen
ich stehe jetzt hier vor einem der
größten möbelhäuser in heinsberg und im
kreis heinsberg
genauso wie in dem rest seiner videos
hier die möbelhäuser wieder öffnen
merkel als ausnahmeregelung bis sechs
wochen geschlossen würde
wir haben jetzt gerade mit einer
mitarbeiterin schon sprechen können das
haus wird auch hier öffnen
trotz der kroner krise kurzes trotz des
epizentrums hier in heinsberg und jetzt
gerade ist hier noch nicht viel los aber
wir erwarten dass viele personen heute
hier kommen werden auch wenn es jetzt
gerade sehr ruhig ist wie ist die
stimmung in heinsberg die stimmung
allgemein ist mittlerweile recht normal
es ist ruhig hier und wir können jetzt
noch gerade sind wir dabei uns darauf
vorzubereiten beziehungsweise der markt
vorzubereiten was jetzt noch kommen
könnte
am 18 darin hatte er geschlossen genauso
wie viele weitere einrichtungshäuser und
bekommen gerade mit der mitarbeiterin
mit dem versprochenen teilte uns mit
dass die auch schon bereits
schutzvorkehrungen getroffen haben die
kasse ist zum beispiel durch plexiglas
geschützt
ein ein- und ausgangsbereich ist
repariert worden und die schilder diese
sind gespannt gleich um 10 uhr wird
eröffnen
ganz herzlichen dank dieser und wie
bringt natürlich weiter wie es dann sich
entwickelt wenn die leben da wirklich
wieder aufmachen dankeschön